madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce lundi 6 ou
monseigneur lustiger décédé hier après
midi à 80 ans et souffrait depuis
plusieurs années d'un cancer et obsèques
seront célébrées vendredi la sécurité
sur les ménages et les attractions des
fêtes foraines est elle suffisante
c'est la question qui se pose après
l'accident survenu en région parisienne
et qui a coûté la vie à deux personnes
c'est déjà la rentrée scolaire dans les
rayons de nombreux magasins beaucoup
commençaient h à la location 2007 sera
versée à partir du 20 de ce mois elle
s'élève à 275 euros 50 tech
la chine est une destination de plus en
plus prisée par les touristes en quête
de dépaysement certaines régions telles
celles du yunnan sont particulièrement
visité laure manaudou licencié par son
club italien une exclusion liée à son
comportement lors de l'open de natation
de paris a expliqué son entraîneur
italien
depuis plusieurs mois il avait été admis
dans un établissement de soins
palliatifs
il est mort dimanche après des semaines
douloureuse liées à son cancer le
cardinal lustiger fut longtemps le
chèque de paris et c'est à notre dame
qu'il célébrait la messe
l'émotion était sensible aujourd'hui où
une foule anonyme est venu signer un
registre de condoléances frédéric
monteil est thomas donzel
que dieu te reçoivent avec toutes nos
prières je n'oublierai jamais cette
messe dite pour mes enfants judéo
chrétien il est un exemple le mot de
condoléances pour certains une
reconnaissance éternelle pour d'autres
comme cet homme
le cardinal lustiger a marié son fils de
confession juive à une catholique un
acte rare
deux traits qui fait partie de la
famille qui nous a quittés je pense que
mais il a adopté quand même beaucoup sur
ce rapprochement des religions et sastre
ça on tient le remercier toute la
journée touristes ou fervent chrétien
amis proches ou simples passants se sont
succédé auprès de ses livres de vie
déposez dès le matin aider les pauvres
les beaucoup de personnes c'est puisqu'à
cardinal c'est un ami quoi quel message
vous allez lui laisser le jeu laissez un
message de paix maximum qui est j'espère
qu'il partira au paradis je souhaite
qu'ils reposent heureux au paradis
est-ce qu'il est connu aux états unis
n'ont pas dit non je le connais surtout
parce que un de mes oncles et
archevêques cette cathédrale qui lui
rend hommage ce soir jeudi et vendredi
le cardinal lustiger la connaissait
parfaitement pour y avoir prêché pendant
25 ans ils veulent également tous les
dimanches il prêchait et françois moins
temporairement appréciez vous avez ce
don de certainement du xiii devrait et
de parler l'anglais n'est pas la langue
de bois à quelques kilomètres de la
radio notre-dame en direct depuis 6h du
matin avec cet homme tout à fait
particulière cette radio c'est jean
marie lustiger en personne qu'il a fondé
en 1981 au téléphone ou au micro des
fils ceux qui ont côtoyé le curé devenu
cardinal ou avant d'être y était prête à
l'hôtel prête il été diacre et dia ça
veut dire serviteur il est resté diack
service de l'église travailler pour
l'église
ce soir à 21h30 de l'archevêque de paris
célébrera une messe souvenir en la
cathédrale notre dame
il avait depuis plusieurs années
beaucoup réduit ses activités en janvier
2007 cependant il avait célébré la messe
d'obsèques de l'abbé pierre en la
cathédrale notre dame
et puis en mai suivant il s'était rendu
à l'académie française pour adresser ses
adieux aux autres académiciens un moment
d'intense émotion à l'image de cet homme
intellectuel brillant parfois abrupt
mais aussi admiré pour sa hauteur
d'esprit et son cari
adèle mostefa et ça bien en mousse
images d'un vendredi saint à paris
images d'un homme qui vivait sa foi
jusqu'au plus profond de son être
la croise le signe de la compassion de
dieu c'est dieu qui porte sur lui ces
conditions souffrance de l'homme pour
aider à changer les choses aient changé
les hommes aussi
lui est né juif et se prénommer aaron
avant de se convertir au catholicisme à
l'âge de 14 ans c'était à orléans où ses
parents l'avaient envoyé pour fuir
l'occupant pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale ça m'est resté à paris sera
déporté à auschwitz et ne reviendra
jamais un brillant parcours dans
l'église pour arrow devenu jean marie
lustiger évêque d'orléans à 53 ans
archevêque de paris et deux ans plus
tard cardinal intronisé par un jean paul
ii dont il se sent très proche
on ne peut pas promettre jamais le
vêtement ce qu'il a appelé lui rappelle
bien que c'est le rôle du martyr et
quand on accepte d'être cardinals et ça
colle accepte d'abord on accepte de
servir dieu dans l'église par toutes les
forces
monseigneur lustiger sera très actif en
poussant les religieux installé à
auschwitz a quitté ce site chargé
d'histoire
il met fin à une polémique entre juifs
et chrétiens et acquiert une stature
internationale
l'observateur hésitent à vous
reconnaître sur le terrain politique en
france aussi en 84 pendant le premier
septennat mitterrand
ils manifestent contre la loi savary et
défend l'école libre stangl le sérieux
le tragique vérité de l'existence des
hommes est engagée par tous il contredit
dans la politique je ne fais pas de la
politique comme un professionnel de la
politique mais je rappelle que dans tout
pour la politique
il a une dimension humaine morale
spirituelle et donc s'ils sont sérieux
redynamiser la foi catholique
un cheval de bataille monseigneur
lustiger fait feu de tout bois de
nouvelles églises une faculté
théologique une radio radio notre-dame
et même une télévision kto sont créés
avec un bug placés devant le fait
accompli par l'archevêque de paris
cardinal lustiger va choisir d'abord de
fonder un journal de son diocèse paris
notre dame puis au tout début de la
vague des radios libres
il va créer radio notre-dame et nouvelle
intuition au moment où les chaînes de
télévision thématiques par le câble et
le satellite se développe mais bien il
aura très vite l'intuition que là aussi
l'église d'être présente pour être
encore plus présent de grands
rassemblements
les jmj en 97 ou la semaine
d'évangilisation paris tout simple que
je garde de lui chez un homme
courageux libre entreprenant audacieux
mille idées à la seconde
c'est ce que j'ai découvert en
travaillant avec lui il ya quelques mois
monseigneur lustiger académiciens avait
rendu visite à ses collègues pour leur
annoncer une fin proche avec gravité
mais aussi avec humour leur promettant
qu'ils se retrouveraient dans l'autre
monde
c'est en effet un singulier parcours qui
a mené ce petit garçon juif d'origine
polonaise dont la mère était morte à
auschwitz jusqu'à la pourpre cardinalice
tu il se disait à la fois juif et
disciples du christ et il a beaucoup
oeuvré pour le rapprochement entre les
juifs et les catholiques les dix sièges
entre et frédéric bon je suis cardinal
juifs et fils d'immigrés
c'est ainsi que ceux des pincettes
figure de l'épiscopat français à 14 ans
aaron lustiger fils de juifs polonais se
convertit au catholicisme
il prend alors le nom de jean marie sans
pour autant renoncer à ses origines
il y donc le catholicisme et l
enfin c'était la forme dans laquelle
intuitivement je me suis je me suis
reconnu il a toujours insisté sur le
fait que c'était dans le judaïsme
qu'existait les véritables racines du
catholicisme donc on peut dire que il
rendait hommage au judaïsme après faire
sa vocation catholique une double
appartenance revendiquée qui en fera un
acteur privilégié du dialogue entre
juifs et chrétiens
mais elle fut parfois mal comprise lors
d'une visite en israël en 1995
le grand rabbin israël lau qualifie jean
marie lustiger de traîtres au peuple
juif et à la religion juive
une polémique qui a fait que
l'archevêque de paris une chose que je
sais c'est que en devenant chrétien je
n'ai pas cessé d'être juif au moins au
moins pour le gouvernement français de
l'époque et au moins pour les nazis
confessons après les mutations du début
son influence ne cesse de croître
il est l'un des premiers auteurs de la
déclaration de repentance de l'épiscopat
français en septembre 97 à drancy
au fur et à mesure que sa démarche a été
mieux comprise et que son authenticité a
été mieux acceptée il sait créer des
relations de très grande fraternité
entre les juifs et lui dialoguer avec
les différentes religions et dépasser
ainsi les querelles de chapelles toutes
ces années le cardinal lustiger aura
cherché à montrer qu'il est possible de
s'entendre au delà de ces différences
monseigneur lustiger qui sera donc
enterré vendredi à paris l'accident dans
un manège de la fête des loges samedi
soir en région parisienne et kas coûté
la vie à deux personnes un père et son
fils pose de nouveau le problème de la
sécurité de ses manèges de plus en plus
puissants de plus en plus élaborées qui
sont montés et démontés au fil des fêtes
foraines et dont le contrôle est
semble-t-il insuffisant puisque une
nouvelle loi est à l'étude
explication karine comme a dit et
mathias ou
hier soir à la fête de palavas-les-flots
les manèges à sensations ont fait le
plein même le booster ce manège
identique à celui qui a causé la mort de
deux personnes et rappelé par son
fabricant
et cet après-midi un arrêté préfectoral
oblige son exploitant arrêter les
machines pas que ça dure quand même tout
le moins doué peut-être davantage aux
mains ce temps la fermeture elle et elle
est claire nette et définitive les
sensations fortes ce n'est pas seulement
un plaisir c'est aussi un marché et la
quête d'adrénaline du public
diop l'innovation dès qu'ils voient une
nouveauté qui veulent l'essayer et c'est
ce qui fait le succès des forains le
succès des parcs d'attraction qui a
toujours des nouveautés pour garantir
les sensations mais aussi la sécurité
le forain compte beaucoup sur lui nous
avions suivi l'installation d'un grand
huit le plus gros d'europe
les 2000 boulons son lycée à la main
puis pendant l'exploitation le fort à
vérifier lui-même son matériel
la chose qu'il faut baisser regardez
déjà la chaîne de monter donc on est
obligé de monter là-haut jusqu'au offert
le poulpe
on fait tout le circuit complet et tous
les jours parce que c'est en remontant
sur le circuit owa s'il ya un problème
et dessus qu'on peut regarder si un
boulon et desserrer parce que ça peut
arriver qu'il brûlerait dessert le grand
huit est monté remonté cinq fois par an
le contrôle technique aux frais du
forain est obligatoire qu'une fois tous
les trois ans établir aussi souvent pour
les manèges à sensation que pour les
quarts ou celles d'enfants un accord a
été conclu avant l'été entre les fora
les autorités pour diviser les manèges
en quatre catégories et pour soumettre
les flux rapide un contrôle annuel
et il est évident que les contrôles ne
sont pas très adapté à ce genre de
manège
donc il faut les adapter le travail
était ferré que la profession et la
direction de la sécurité civile
reste à valider le document mercredi les
forains seront reçus au ministère de
l'intérieur une proposition de loi
renforçant la sécurité devrait être
étudiée dès septembre et aujourd'hui la
famille des victimes de cet accident est
évidemment en état de choc d'autant que
la maman assisté au drame elle a vu la
nacelle dans lequel se trouvait son
époux ses deux fils et leron s'écraser
devant elle frédéric rota et caroline y
prêche tenons rencontré quand elle nous
reçoit très tôt ce matin
marie-jeanne dubuc est toujours en état
de choc très affaiblis ou presque sans
voix
samedi dernier toute sa famille avaient
décidé de faire la fête à saint germain
en laye mais l'accident du booster à
briser s'habitueront son mari et son
jeune fils de 21 ans devant ses yeux il
ne sait que je décroche et ceux projetés
et non parties poussant celui sur un le
même sillage la commencer le carnage
une responsable du manège seront pris
conscience elle ça s'est arrêté tout de
suite me dis que c'est tellement une
force tellement que se séparer de suite
sa tournée jeudi c'est un carnage et le
monfils a eu le temps de se déchirer
l'attraction trèbes élémentaire rien
arrivé cet enchaînement c'est comme
indique le manège a été révisée 2006
vient d'accorder savez entre 2006 et
la neige je suppose qu'ils font pas
d'éloges je pense que cette méfiance que
je suis dire je pense que ça n'est que
parce que ça m'arrive que parce que t'es
pas à sainte marie jeanne dubuc ainsi
que son beau frère blessé dans
l'accident envisage de porter plainte
contre le forain mais aussi contre le
constructeur du manège pour éviter
distille d'autres drames heureuse issue
pour le petit alexandre 12 ans kidnappée
à l'île de la réunion vendredi dernier
par une set il a été retrouvé hier
quinze personnes ont été arrêtées deux
secrétaires d'état d'autres à
l'outre-mer christian estrosi promet de
surveiller tout particulièrement les
phénomènes sectaires sur tous les
territoires de france de neil stein 48
heures de traque pour retrouver cet
homme
juliano verbard un gourou de 25 ans
c'est lui qui a organisé avec ses
adeptes le rapt du petit alexandre
hier soir la secte a été arrêté sous les
cris d'une foule en colère
alexandre lui a été retrouvé sain et
sauf comme le montre cette photo prise
après sa libération
transféré à l'hôpital sa mère et son
oncle ont pu le voir quelques minutes
là j'ai mis des très choqué
beaucoup donné
contre ceux qui ont agressé
quelques détails
s'ils ont mis dans qu'offre la voiture
hollande
hormis ennuis
il a dormi
il faudrait donc
la peine manger
mais il a subi aucune violence et
l'enfant a passé sa captivité dans ces
maisons louées par la secte l'une
servait de lieu de détention
l'autre de chapelle car pour les adeptes
alexandre était considéré comme l'élu le
futur messie celui qui devait succéder à
giuliano verbard surnommé petit lys
d'amour une fois par mois le gourou
affirmé entendre la vierge lors de
cérémonies dont il faisait payer
l'entrée mais depuis quatre ans l'homme
était en cavale
en 2006 il avait été condamné par
contumace à 15 ans de prison pour viol
sur mineure le gouvernement a annoncé la
dissolution de la secte ce soir ses
membres sont en garde à vue il devrait
être mis en examen pour enlèvement et
séquestration en bande organisée hier
dans le lot un agriculteur s'est suicidé
dans son champ en cependant un arbre on
a retrouvé à ses pieds un pied de maïs à
un tract appelant à une manifestation
anti ogm les militants visés son
exploitation
cet homme avait planter du maïs ogm pour
l'alimentation animale en avril dernier
et sa mort lance ce débat ce harcèlement
dont sont l'objet certains agriculteurs
qui ont reçu l'autorisation de cultiver
ces plantes transgéniques
françois jullien pieds noirs avec merial
la saga et nicolas aubert il ne s'est
pas pendu dans sa maison ni dans sa
grange non il a choisi son chance à
terre comme un symbole pour se suicider
monsieur lagorce a été retrouvé mort
hier pendu à un arbre
face à sa parcelle de maïs transgénique
à ses pieds l'homme a disposé du maïs et
ce tract des militants anti ogm menaçait
de pique [ __ ] sur son exploitation
depuis un an ce père de quatre enfants
cultivaient la peur liée à ce type
d'agriculture controversé il avait même
caché à son époux son choix pour les ogm
il est certain qu'il y a eu un un lien
entre la perspective de la manifestation
anti ogm qui devait avoir lieu à
proximité de la parcelle de monsieur
lagorce en fin de matinée et son geste
fatal
suite à ce drame les militants anti ogm
ont annulé leur pique nique ne voulait
pas fauché le champ de l'agriculteur
mais susciter le débat sur les ogm
c'est sûr qu'après un tel fait marquant
ça fait réfléchir sur les formes
d'action des actions souvent controversé
et très musclé les militants fauche des
champs entiers des silos à grains sont
complètement noyé en novembre 2006 cet
agriculteur à bout sur son fusil tirs en
l'air mais il est vite maîtrisé
le suicide de ce week end est le drame
de trop pour les producteurs de maïs
transgénique
et c'est vrai qu'il ya une telle
pression que je peux comprendre le geste
de cet agriculteur
moi même j'ai été je suis vite j'ai été
victime je suis victime de pressions du
harcèlement de d'agressions verbales de
menaces de mort d'autres actions anti
ogm sont prévues dans des champs au mois
d'août mais les ministres de l'écologie
et de l'agriculture ont appelé à
l'apaisement
la rentrée scolaire se profile avec déjà
la location fixé cette année à 272 euros
57 par enfant de 6 à 16 ans elle sera
versée à partir du 20 août est déjà dans
les supermarchés les fournitures
scolaires sont en rayon pour certaines
familles c'est l'occasion de faire des
achats avant même de partir en vacances
autre option certains magasins
spécialisés s'occupe de tout il suffit
de leur laisser la liste donnée par
l'école reportage
yacine email jeannette et à la location
des cahiers un rêve de parents pendant
les vacances cette papetière fait les
courses à leur place les parents
viennent déposer leurs listes
un petit peu à la vence
on leur prépare et après on les appelle
consulté près c'est plus agréable pour
eux c'est plus agréable pour nous parce
qu'après il n'y a pas de stress avec
l'ess et les affaires tournent bien 300
paniers à préparer d'ici à la fin de
l'été mais c'est dans les supermarchés
que ce fait toujours la majorité des
achats ici 800 produits sont vendus
spécialement pour la rentrée je lis
comme couleur les mamies ça sert à ça
aussi acheter des choses qu'elle aime
les côtés en les appelait déjà
côté budget la rentrée coûte 170 euros
en moyenne pour un élève de primaire le
double pour un collégien
mais à une condition ne pas céder aux
tentations les prêts soit pas trop cher
mais on essaie de fonds
comprendre les affaires s'il aime sans
abuser non plus les fournitures les
familles les achètent de plus en plus
tôt pour éviter la cohue résultats plus
le temps passe plus le choix se réduit
donc nous avons installé nos frais
incartade surtout début du mois de
juillet ce sur toute l'allée centrale
car il s'agit du premier achat des
parents aujourd'hui on a commencé à le
réduire au profit du textile faire une
grosse partie de notre clientèle la
belge a déjà agi seul car fans en
septembre douze millions d'élèves
reprendront le chemin de l'école
près de trois millions d'entre eux
bénéficieront de l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire
et puis il ya tous ceux qui ne partent
pas du tout en vacances
un français sur cinq très exactement
certains jeunes restent avec leurs
copains au pied de leur immeuble
d'autres fréquentent les bases loisirs
reportage à cergy-pontoise arnault
compte et la vie de fossard côté aussi
le parfum des vacances la famille ramos
le trouve à une vingtaine de kilomètre
de la maison sur cette base de loisirs
en région parisienne
carlos isabelle et leurs deux filles
viennent ici se mettre au vert deux à
trois fois par semaine avec 2500 euros
net par mois
c'est tout ce qu'ils peuvent se
permettre cette année on peut partir la
surface mais peut-être bord de la mer
même deux personnes qui travaillent du
mal à s'en sortir
moi je préfère donner à manger à mes
voeux à mes fils que partir et leucan
génie à 12 ans elle rêve d'îles
paradisiaques et de boîtes de nuit sa
meilleure amie elle revient de tunisie
pas tout à fait les mêmes vacances qu'à
paris moi
attraper des coûts seraient en phase
aller avec une amie à l'arrière-plan de
ce paysage de vacances la banlieue de
cergy-pontoise ici pour beaucoup partir
ne serait ce que quelques jours est un
luxe ces jeunes n'ont pour certains
jamais quitté le bitume de la cité
alors bien sûr les maisons de quartier
proposent des activités mais difficile
tout de même de ne pas s'ennuyer comme
il dit me sont venues vers 14h15 heure
c'est souvent ce qui fait du foot
français à partir d'un gilet une in
hawaï comme ça une île où on s'amuse
bien et en france une famille sur cinq
n'en mène jamais ses enfants en vacances
et puis à partir du 13 août
l'électricité coûtera plus cher + 1 1 %
pour les particuliers + 1 5 % pour le
trafic professionnel un impact sur la
facture mensuelle qui sera inférieur à 1
euro par mois pour les ménages sur le
ministre de l'écologie jean louis borloo
une spéléologue baisse de 49 ans est
bloquée depuis dimanche après midi au
fond d'un gouffre près de la pierre
saint martin dans les pyrénées
atlantiques
elle souffre d'une fracture ouverte du
pied une équipe médicalisée a pu la
recoudre
mais il faut la faire sortir en brancard
ce qui s'annonce long et difficile
jean françois feer et et marine masson
ils attendent anxieux le retour de leurs
femmes et ami paul ii bis et didier
sauvage était au fond de la grotte avec
la victime quand l'accident s'est
produit
le premier en plus de dix années de
spéléologie professionnels
annette a appuyé sur la paroi d'une
galerie et le pavois c'était une
l'embauché est tombé sur un demi mètre
sur son quai
s'apaisaient peut-être 50 kilos en plus
quand ça lui a écrit les premiers
secours hier ont pu soigner cette
fracture du pied
la configuration du lieu n'a pas
compliqué l'intervention elle n'a jamais
été en danger vital mais elle avait
notamment des fractures ouvertes des
orteils qui ont été refermés par le
médecin et il a maintenant mais si ce
qu'elle peut pas se poser le pied donc
ça va nécessiter un brin garde âge sur
quittent eux la cavité casino mais ce
qui rend encore plus complexe les
opérations c'est l'accès à cette cavité
à 2100 mètres d'altitude à plus de deux
heures de marche du village de la pierre
saint martin les secours doivent ensuite
descendre à 600 mètres de profondeur et
évoluer dans une galerie de trois
kilomètres tout au fond il ya été
aménagé un bivouac
il faut également sécuriser les parois
amener le matériel relayer les équipes
au pc sécurité les effectifs sont
nombreux les prévisions météo ne sont
pas bonnes sur la pierre saint martin ce
soir la pluie redouble et brouillards
sont épais résultat les hélicoptères ne
décolle pas et les secours sont
ralenties la spéléologues ne sera pas
remonter à la surface avant au moins
demain soir aux etats-unis la campagne
électorale en vue de l'élection
présidentielle de 2008 bat son plein
dans le camp démocrate
les candidats à l'investiture ne se font
pas de cadeaux hillary clinton sénatrice
de new york creuse des cas avec son
rival barack obama en reportage à new
york signé martine laroche-joubert et
pascal offrir c'est un duel à fleurets
mouchetés hillary clinton creuse l'écart
avec barack obama 21 points de plus mais
pour elle la partie n'est pas toujours
gagné d'avancé ici devant des blogueurs
d'un site progressiste à chicago a
priori hostile
elle met les rieurs de en fait je lis
les blogs
je me dis il exagère et parfois je
trouve ça intéressant les premières
passes d'armes commence il ya une
quinzaine de jours à l'affrontement sur
la méthode de politique étrangère seriez
vous prêt à rencontrer les leaders de
l'iran de la syrie de cuba du venezuela
leur demande à l'internaute
non je le ferai le fait de ne pas parler
à ces pays des ridicules
moi je ne veux pas promettre de
rencontrer ces chefs d'état je ne veux
pas être utilisé à des fins de
propagande
hilary enfonce le clou à la radio obama
accuse l ena leaf et irresponsables
contre attaque d'obama oui on n'a pas de
politique étrangère efficace quand on ne
se parle pas si nous avions écouté la
sagesse populaire nous ne serions pas
dans ce bourbier irakien
en revanche barack obama se dit prêt à
des frappes militaires contre al qaïda
au pakistan
un duel où chacun joue de ces êtres
contre le charisme du sénateur de
l'illinois
hilary affiche un décolleté un peu plus
sexy que d'habitude
une nouvelle stratégie
ancien reporter sans frontières a
dénoncé aujourd'hui à pékin le monde de
liberté d'expression un an avant
l'ouverture des jeux olympiques une
douzaine de journalistes étrangers ont
été interpellés au cours de cette
manifestation
il estime que la chine n'a pas tenu ses
promesses en matière de droits de
l'homme et de liberté des médias
la chine qui devient une destination
touristique très prisée elle est
désormais deuxième au monde après la
france et devant l'espagne
beaucoup d'étrangers mais aussi beaucoup
de chinois qui visitent leur pays un
pays aussi vaste que l'europe avait
quelques régions de prédilection comme
le yunnan au sud ou encore le tibet
historique visiter exploration avec loïc
de la mornais et bruno carette à la
multi millénaire mystérieuse et
inexplorée mais il ne faut jamais
oublier qu'en chine il y a avant tout
les chinois les chiffres donnent le
vertige
l'an dernier les autorités ont
enregistré 1,3 milliard de séjours
touristiques la classe moyenne chinoise
découvre son propre pays en faisant
d'ores et déjà le plus grand marché
touristique intérieure du monde dans la
vieille ville de lijiang appelée la
venise du yunnan
ce n'est pas la période de pointe non la
saison aux têtes en janvier février lors
du nouvel an chinois
aujourd'hui c'est une moyenne perdu dans
la masse des touristes chinois
les occidentaux et notamment les
français sont de plus en plus nombreux
et façonné par l'asie c'est mon
cinquième voyage en asie je crois que la
chine est tellement démesuré pour un
français que c'est quelque chose qui ne
peut qu'attirer que tu mens pas dans sa
démesure et en même temps son histoire
qui entend passer extraordinaire pour
nous est exceptionnel joël le caveau
ressent lui est là depuis sept ans ce
breton installé à lee jang a vu
débarquer les premiers touristes
français il y a trois ans à peine les
premiers français que j'ai vu jeudi
réussie en chine
à mon avis avait été d informer sur ce
qu'était la chaîne dont qu'ils
arrivaient avec le tout un tas de
préjugés dernier au type et avec leur
pharmacie avec tout ce qu'il fallait
alors que le livre ils peuvent pas dire
qu'ils ont découvert qu'ils pouvaient
venir en toute sécurité
le soir la vieille ville construite sous
la dynastie song il ya 800 ans ce débris
même ici dans cette lointaine province à
3000 km de pékin
on est loin des clichés de la chine
traditionnelle le communiste musique
techno chinoise à fond jeunes juchés sur
les toits une bière à la main comme
cette étudiante qui interpelle un
passant écrit par ici
ici l'aéroport le plus proche est à 15
heures de route
bienvenue au chin rail qu'on appelle le
tibet historique
loin de la région touristique de l'aca
c'est une des provinces les plus
reculées encore secrète et préserver un
territoire grand comme la france où l'on
se chauffe en ramassant les bulls de
yack un far west où quasiment personne
ne comprend le chinois et où les
routiers en d'étranges couture son
chauffeur explique qu'il doit bénir les
cols de montagne pour lui assurer la
sécurité sur la route
dans ce temple reculé en pleine montagne
est enserré dans une toile de banderoles
de prière pas un visage des projets les
premiers étrangers que j'ai vu c'était
des pèlerins indien il ya trois ans mais
vous vous êtes les premiers occidentaux
jugent nantes
il faut aller à youssou petite bourgade
de 250000 habitants pour trouver des
touristes et encore c'est sur les
hauteurs de la ville au détour d'un
monastère que l'on déniche deux
intrépides américaine en chine et au
tibet en particulier
vous voyez les gens la vie la vraie vie
chez nous dans le pays où l'on peut tout
est aseptisé cacher je suis vraiment
tombée amoureuse de cet endroit c'est
quand même plus intéressant que de faire
du shopping à hong kong
le chinois il reste une région
presqu'un violée mais pour combien de
temps encore
dans moins de cinq ans la chine
détrônera la france et deviendra la
première destination touristique au
monde
un résultat logique dans ce pays de la
démesure où tous les chiffres sont plus
grands à l'image de ces banales cols
routiers qui sont déjà plus haut que
notre mont blanc nouvelle rupture entre
laure manaudou et son entraîneur cette
fois c'est le club italien qui l'avait
accueillie en mai après son départ au
tonitruant du cannet qui a décidé de
l'exclure
l'entraîneur est à dire juge que son
attitude lors de l'open de paris n'est
pas acceptable
l'explication julien benedetto avec
frédéric bazille l'idylle aura duré
trois mois
ce soir laure manaudou n'a plus
d'entraîneur la sportive préférée des
français est exclu du club de turin pour
son entraîneur c'est la championne
olympique du caprice elle goûte
modérément la préparation sauce
italienne
le clash était inévitable
entre paulo bento et l ça n'a jamais été
la dolce vita
on l'a bien vu ce week end à l'open de
paris la championne a proprement ignorée
son entraîneur italien lui préférant
souvent la compagnie de son téléphone
portable
échauffement écourtée massage ap la
nageuse reconnaît son manque
d'investissement
je ne me suis pas fait ma cg pas tout
fait pour un montant non plus nos coeurs
c'est normal
peut-être pas ce chapelet si manaudou et
l ingérable pas facile d'entraîner l'or
au quotidien philippe lucas l'a appris à
ses dépens congédié par la championne il
ya trois mois après l'avoir conduit au
titre olympique et mondial
et quand elle part à turin pour se
rapprocher de son fiancé
l'expérience tourne au fiasco
normal un mois des jeux olympiques de
pékin
laure manaudou se retrouve sans
entraîneur sans structure inquiétant
pour les dirigeants de la natation
française
là on est on est au bord du gouffre
c'est à dire que début septembre il faut
qu'elle serait une structure en tout cas
qu'elles en fassent le choix s'il a fait
ce pas ce choix
je pense qu'il faut pas se voiler la
face on va à la catastrophe pour les
joueurs la fédération est d'ores et déjà
en mesure de lui fournir une liste de
cinq entraîneurs à laure manaudou de
faire son choix
mais ce sera dans trois semaines après
ses vacances aux états-unis
spectaculaire accident lors d'une
compétition de voitures de course ses
monoplaces à pendik affrontent sur des
circuits ovales et développe 600 chevaux
l'accident fort heureusement n'a passé
de victime
en dépit de son côté extrêmement
spectaculaire l'épreuve se déroulait
dans le michigan brooklyn
et puis à 7 se tient en ce moment le
festival fiest'a sète
cette année un hommage particulier a été
rendu à james brown hier soir ses
chansons mais aussi une partie de son
équipe était à l'honneur jusqu'à 2
heures du matin l'ambiance était à la
soul music avec au milieu de la foule
veronica guillaume et cyril payet
un peu comme sur un ring dans la lumière
ça déjà ça lui aurait pu faire
james brown aurait été mais l'hommage
ses anciens comparses se plaisent à le
croire fred wesley et pee wee ellis
l'ont accompagné si longtemps j'ai
appris ça lui les barras toi de tout ce
qu'on enseigne à l'école oublie tout ça
même si tu crois que ça va pas aller
accepte l'idée que si tu ressens c'est
que c'est bon
james brown
ils ont connu jeunes ils avaient tous du
talent à revendre et chacun s'est
inspiré de monde
il était sain qui hier choristes
musicien ou compositeur 5
apôtre du dieu de la soul témoins
d'époque différentes jamais réunis sur
scène avant ce soir
nous avons fait du coeur
on
son esprit vit en chacun de nous je me
souviens quand j'étais sur scène avec
lui elle regarder danser chanter avec
toujours ce sourire sur son visage
je me disait regarde ce type il est
extraordinaire rien n'est perdu
ni leur audace ni son talent monsieur
dynamite les a laissés en décembre
dernier mais à tous il a donné la
liberté immense de voir plus loin
le journaliste écrivain henri amouroux
est décédée dimanche dans sa maison du
calvados ancien directeur de sud ouest
sera inhumé près de bordeaux il avait
écrit plusieurs volumes d'histoire sur
le comportement des français sous
l'occupation portrait signé jane benzema
toute sa vie henri amouroux s'est penché
sur une époque 1940-1945 la vie des
français durant la seconde guerre
mondiale une période ô combien complexe
de faire comprendre que les français ont
évolué c'est le faire comprendre que si
on regarde et français de 40 avec les
lunettes de 44 on est sûr se [ __ ]
dedans et de rien comprendre l'histoire
de entre 40 et 44 c'est le même peuple
et c'est en vérité cnil peuples
différents
une oeuvre la grande histoire des
français sous l'occupation
dix volumes plus de 2 millions
d'exemplaires vendus pétain vichy la
collaboration sa vision choque certains
historiens dans son livre quarante
millions de pétainistes
il évoque la france de la défaite qui se
rangent consentante derrière le maréchal
pétain 40 millions de pétainistes dont
maurice papon en 1997 henri amouroux
témoigne en faveur de l'ancien préfet de
gironde
c'est la polémique historien mais aussi
journalistes il participe à la fondation
de sud-ouest dirige france soir élu à
l'académie des sciences morales et
politiques henri amouroux laisse l'image
d'un homme qui a toujours porté sur son
époque un regard aiguisé et puis
disparition aussi de héler de rothschild
banquiers mais aussi propriétaire de
château lafite rothschild dont il avait
repris la gestion après l'occupation
nazie en 1946 sauvant ainsi ce domaine
d'exception le plus grand de tous les
châteaux bordelais élite rothschild a
succombé à une crise cardiaque à l'âge
de 90 ans
ainsi se termine ce journal à suivre la
météo de valérie alexandre 20h50 le film
goldfinger avec sean connery dans le
rôle de james bond
après journal de minuit de jean claude
renaud un hommage à monseigneur lustiger
dans les 4 vérités de télématin bernard
lapasset le président de la fédération
française de rugby
13h olivier galzi quant à moi je vous
retrouve demain à 20h très bonne soirée
sur france 2 avoir
le ministre
une dignité
les